you're one of my favorite people I mean
the Brian graser producer Brian graser
his work includes hits like Apollo 13
The Da Vinci Code and the Oscar winning
A Beautiful Mind starring Russell Crow
If I find an actor to be a superstar to
be really hard to work with but if I
give him power as a leader he will lead
us to success I think it's how progress
happens right because when you talk
about the system and the man what we
really mean is someone else is making
decisions for us yes that someone else
is taking away our agency but if you
give the agency back then they feel I'm
an adventurer I'm discovering I'm in
charge and I'll discover within the
boundaries and I think a lot of people
in leadership positions you know they
fear giving away power they fear giving
away responsibility but the reality is
the total opposite which is when you
give people responsibility they tend to
rise to the occasion I think it's
accountability right it's accountability